attention jean-michel pour l'instant
c'est bon il y là il a été très bon
sabrina les i c'est trop j'ai trop
poussé mais dagong bourgade regardez
regardez secret ça peut être tout les
notes au retour alors attention sur
michel ne regardez pas non alors gas gas
gas des sabres il a qui sont ils et qui
a disparu il a une bonne de meuf
non mais non elle est magnifique ouais
yade oui quoi l'idée des courbes des
courbes d'audience franck gastambide moi
et j'ai la mère serveuse cabine amf jean
michel qu'est-ce que vous prenez garde
époux franck agah de gamme
alors attendez on va voir d'ailleurs le
blast qu'il y avait derrière franck
allongement
et d'ailleurs à bord
non je change bien un truc de fou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]